a San Francisco Whole Foods store has
closed after having been open for just
one year the store closed because of
high crime and dangerous conditions for
employees junkies are reportedly
regularly loitering and shooting up
around the store it is not a pleasant
shopping experience
so why are the bums and the criminals
loitering around the store why is crime
so high
it's because San Francisco's elected
officials have stopped enforcing the law
arrests have fallen dramatically in
recent years the mayor has called to
defund the police
it's a cautionary tale not just for
major cities but for every Locale that
liberalism has infected
it's an answer to the question that
liberals always bring up when they run
out of arguments the question is
how does it affect you
what do you mean people shouldn't be
able to do drugs how does it affect you
what do you mean men shouldn't strap on
stilettos and saunter into the Ladies
Room how does it affect you
it affects me
and you and all of us because we live in
society
and you can't live comfortably in a
chaotic Society if you had the choice of
being the poorest man in a prosperous
Society or the richest man in a
collapsing Society you would choose the
prosperous Society every time
no man is an island entire of itself we
are social beings San Francisco
is one of the richest places in America
but it's wealthy residents can't have
Whole Foods can't have a supermarket
they can't walk down the street without
fear of being murdered like the poor
cash app founder in San Francisco last
week
how does social collapse affect us it
affects our whole way of life
what right do we have to impose a better
way of life our preferred way of life on
the druggies and the bums and the
criminals we have the right of
self-government
and we'd better start reasserting that
right before the whole country turns
into one gigantic San Francisco I'm
Michael Knowles it's the Michael Knowles
show
[Music]
welcome back to the show this episode is
brought to you by one of my absolute
favorite companies on Earth good
ranchers free bacon great meat a secure
price and an extra 20 bucks off with my
code Knowles head to goodranters.com use
my code Knowles for twenty dollars off
your order
we've got some real updates coming into
the latest attacks on Democracy our
sacred
here in my state of Tennessee we get the
Tennessee three who led a riot at the
Capitol but this was a good Riot it's a
it was a good riot at the Capitol in
Tennessee it was a bad riot in
Washington D.C we'll get into that but
there's there's some some new footage of
one of these Tennessee three that has
appeared that is
It Makes You Weep for our democracy
we'll get to that in just a little bit
first though first though
speaking of violence Korean Champion
over at the White House
is pushing a new assault weapons ban the
libs are trying to take your AR-15s one
of the most popular guns in America
they're trying to take those guns and
they are not merely fear-mongering over
the guns they are now out right lying
about them
we need Congress to act and if you think
about uh assault assault weapons ban we
know when we saw when the president was
involved in 1994 to get that done we saw
we saw a gun violence go down when it's
Sunset 10 years later it went back up so
we know what could work and that's why
you continue to hear the president
calling on Congress to take action
that just isn't true
on this show I I always try to give the
libs the benefit of the doubt I try to
see the point that maybe they're trying
to make that's obscured by their
ideology I try to be as charitable in my
view as I possibly can but you know
but what she said just isn't true
there's there's no way for me to
complicate this or to find some Nuance
she's just wrong I have to give a hat to
to Dana lash for finding that clip and
she debunked it very very well a number
of conservatives are doing that right
now it isn't true that the
doj in July of 2004
observed that the assault weapons ban
did not do that the doj concluded that
it could not credit the ban with any
drop in gun violence Jamma this is the
Journal of the American Medical
Association we've got an article here
from 2017.
observed that specific laws directed at
firearm trafficking improving child
safety or the Banning of military style
assault weapons were not associated with
changes in firearm homicide rates I've
got another paper here this is from just
January of this year from the Rand
Corporation concludes pretty much the
very same thing
it's just not true the White House is
just lying they have no arguments on
their side and so they're just going to
double down on a lie and it is the
definition of Madness to do the very
same thing over and over again and
expect different results
it's just it's just not true if they had
good arguments they would make them they
don't so they lie to you we should not
give this any quarter any Republican who
votes for the so-called assault weapons
ban is just a complete tool a total
squish is no reasoning with that kind of
a Republican because there's no reason
in this debate speaking of debates I
mentioned yesterday on the show
how excited I am at the prospect of this
debate that I'm having in at the
University of Pittsburgh scheduled by
the Intercollegiate Studies Institute
with uh Professor Donald McCloskey who
now goes by Deirdre he identifies as
transgender he's a distinguished
professor and we were to debate
transgenderism and Womanhood and who
decides on this and this has been
scheduled for a long time all sorts of
petitions and political calls to shut
down the debate the professor had
previously said that he hates me he
specifically called me a fascist and all
sorts of mean names but said that we
have to debate you shouldn't run away
from debates
he pulled out of the debate he pulled
out of debate it was obviously keeping
him up at night and when you want to
sleep well at night you got to check out
Helix sleep right now go to
helixsleep.com Knowles after a Long
Day's Work why are you sacrificing a
good night's sleep with a terrible
mattress you got to check out Helix
mattress Helix is a premium mattress
brand that provides tailored mattresses
based on your unique sleep preferences
the Helix lineup includes 14 unique
mattresses including a collection of
luxury models a mattress for Big and
Tall sleepers and even a mattress made
just for kids I've had my Helix for
almost three years now I love it I adore
it are you nervous about buying a
mattress online now you don't have to be
Helix has a sleep quiz that matches your
body type and sleep preferences to the
perfect mattress for you because why
would you buy a mattress made for
someone else get out of my mattress I'm
a married man go to Helix sleep.com
slash Knowles take their two minute
sleep quiz and find the perfect mattress
for your body and sleep type it will
come straight to your door for free
Helix has a 10-year warranty and you get
to try it out for 100 at nights
risk-free they will even pick it up for
you if you don't love it you're not
gonna have to worry about that because
you will love it they're financing
options and flexible payment plans make
it so that a great night's sleep is
never far away Helix is offering 20 off
all mattress orders and two free pillows
for our listeners go right now to Helix
sleep.com Knowles with Helix better
sleep starts
now
I was contacted by the media yesterday
shortly after my show asking me for
comment on Professor McCloskey's pulling
out of this debate with me at the
University of Pittsburgh
so then I looked at the Articles to see
what Professor McCloskey was saying here
and according to this article from the
city paper quote since discovering
Knowles to be utterly uninterested in
finding the truth and instead quote
interested in stirring up hatred and
violence toward people who do not fit
his extremely conservative Catholic
beliefs she meaning he Donald McCloskey
has dropped out of the event
McCloskey says
he quote is very willing to debate on
the issue just not with Knowles
then they say I made headlines for
calling for the eradication of
transgenderism the whole ideology from
public life at CPAC so
this is very curious that Professor
McCloskey would drop out now because it
is true both Professor McCloskey and I
were invited by isi to debate before my
CPAC speech and before the media lied
about what I said in the White House
lied about what I said
but then after the speech
Professor McCloskey reiterated his
desire to debate the issue
and he called me all sorts of mean names
he called me a fascist he called me an
anti-jesus Catholic
he identifies not just as a woman but as
Episcopalian so he I guess there was a
an anti-catholic dig but he said
regardless we need to debate these ideas
not not run away from them not not hide
them or suppress them okay
then we had a pre-debate call
so this this is a call with the
organizers and me and Professor
McCloskey and we discussed what we'd
like to
talk about during the debate and he
started off quite rude and impolite on
the call but by the end he had sort of
warmed up a little bit and uh I I I I
don't know I guess he just didn't know
very much about me and I think he
expected me to be just some bomb
throwing you know uh
uh provocateur and so when I said on the
call that no my objection is just that I
don't think the transgender people is a
is a real ontological category I think
their people are confused about their
sex but that's not a real distinct
category of being and when I said that
my issue here is uh an epistemological
disagreement and an anthropological
disagreement and here's why I think
transgenderism is false and furthermore
here's why I think that the state has a
role in in regulating the basic
definitions of these things Professor
McCloskey seemed surprised by that
he
started out the phone call by
insinuating that I'm poorly educated and
don't have any idea what I'm talking
about but but by the end of the call he
he didn't really have that posture
anymore and it one from one point
actually when he was surprised that I
said that I do support the state having
a role in regulating these things he
said oh I guess you're a consistent
conservative you know if if I were not
if I were a Libertarian or something
like that then he could have caught me
in a bit of hypocrisy but but no I was
just explaining my view it's the basic
conservative view it's the basic view
that everybody held on this issue until
about eight years ago it's the view that
even liberal Democrats held until about
eight years ago it's based on an
understanding of human nature that dates
back at least 2 300 years and uh based
on a traditional epistemology that
served our civilization very very well
and anyway I I don't mean any of that to
uh try to persuade Professor McCloskey
to come into the debate I just mentioned
that to point out that his excuse as to
why he's pulling out is not honest
Professor McCloskey knew my views on
this subject he's known them for well
over a month at least and then we even
had a call about it a couple of weeks
ago after the call he reiterated his
desire to have the debate nothing has
changed since then
so I I suspect all that's changed is
he knows that he can't win the debate
it's not not a knock on his intelligence
it's not a knock on his education
but he's he's just wrong he's he's
defending an indefensible position
so I think he could have seemed to win
the debate if I were just a bomb thrower
and I were just a provocateur and
calling people all sorts of names the
way that he was calling me names maybe
then he could have appeared like the
adult in the room but because that's not
my style and because he
after that phone call had been a little
bit more familiar with my style I think
he realized there was just no
win for him and so he
contradicted his previous View that we
have to debate these things in public
and we need to Hash these things out in
the free Marketplace of ideas and now
he's just he's just run away from the
debate I've got a speech today in East
Tennessee State University over in
Johnson City and then I've got a speech
tomorrow at the University of Wisconsin
Superior
so if you're around head on over there
you can reserve tickets online we'll see
you out there it's not that I have a
lack of speaking opportunities over the
next few weeks
but I was looking forward to this debate
and hashing out this issue that
everybody seems so focused on that's
unfortunate because I know that some
people in this audience had made plans
to attend the debate I I know that there
were obviously going to be a lot of
protests and there were always hecklers
and all sorts of miscreants but it's not
doesn't come from our side it's not the
conservatives who do that it's always
the people on Professor McCloskey's side
of the debate who disrupt these events
so we were prepared for that and it's
unfortunate so we're we're looking for a
replacement I intend to to do some kind
of event at Pitt we're working on seeing
if anyone else will come in but I think
it's very telling
that as as I've said from the beginning
of this whole debate
Prospect I've said if I'm going to have
this debate I want it to be with a
really serious person I want it to be
with the person who can make the
strongest argument for transgenderism
that there is I don't want some two-bit
Hustler from YouTube or something I want
a distinguished
scholar
and uh it's very telling that a
distinguished Professor with multiple
degrees from Harvard three of them and
half a dozen honorary doctorates and two
dozen academic Publications
even he does not feel that he can debate
the issue of transgenderism
and he and he he would rather concede
the debate before it begins than lose in
front of the C-SPAN cameras because also
C-SPAN was going to to air this debate
so not surprising and I'm happy to take
a win by default
happy to take this technical Victory but
it's too bad that we couldn't have the
debate in public it's too bad that he he
did not have the courage of his
convictions convictions both about
transgenderism and about the role of
debate in society
it proves an old adage
which is that you can always tell a
Harvard man but you can't tell him much
speaking of gender
sometimes you will hear the libs say
that they are not in fact transiting the
kids
out of one side of the mouth they say
it's very important that we trans the
kids this is gender reforming health
care we have to give it to everybody
even the White House says this but then
at the other side of your mouth when
when a conservative criticizes this idea
they'll say no we're not doing that this
is a right-wing conspiracy theory we're
not we're not translating the kids and
you say well you're putting them in
gender affirming therapy well yes that's
true
and you're putting them on puberty
blockers say yes that's true
you're putting them on cross-sex
hormones sometimes yes that's true
so how are you not transiting the kids
and what they will say is well we're not
performing the surgeries on them we're
not chopping off their body parts we
wait until 18 to do that but that's not
true
North Carolina Surgery Clinic
has just been caught performing the
gender surgery on young girls as young
as 14.
the Cosmetic concierge which is a
Plastic Surgery Clinic in Charlotte
performed elective double mastectomies
on these young teenage girls including
at the very least one 14 year old this
according to reports from Redux
they've got images of this it's not even
just
records they've got images showing the
results of Top surgery procedures which
is where these quacks chop off the
breasts healthy breasts of young girls
who are having a little bit of body
discomfort as they go through puberty
you know like every single teenage girl
ever in human history but what they
decide to do is chop off their healthy
body parts
the photos include lots of other girls
too though 16 16 year olds 15 year olds
and and 14 year olds this is happening
don't let them tell you that this isn't
happening
it is
don't let them tell you that they're not
defunding the police they are don't let
them tell you that they're not putting
porn in schools elementary schools they
are we've got the pictures we've got the
receipts it is happening and their only
argument against it now is just to lie
they're just lying
there's no engaging in a good faith
dialogue and finding the Nuance here
they're just they're doing very bad
things and they're trying to cover it up
and the only way to deal with that is to
Outlaw it and then bring down the weight
of government and the forest and the
state and the justice system to punish
the people who do these kinds of evil
evil acts speaking of
medical malpractice and our Judicial
System huge win from the courts major
major win for pro-life this is the
biggest win for pro-life since
the overruling of Roe v Wade in the
Dobbs decision U.S District Judge
Matthew Cash Mark I'm almost certainly
mispronouncing that name
suspended the fda's long-time approval
of the abortion drug mithopristone
the government has one week to appeal
this decision but the federal judge has
has suspended the FDA approval of myth
of christone which was granted more than
20 years ago
and this drug is used in tandem with
another drug misoprostol to kill babies
up until about 10 weeks old
why does this matter
well we think about abortion as the
woman goes into the abortion Mill and
the quacks and the witches and the
satanic doctors go in and kill the
babies that's what we picture
but
more than half of U.S abortions are not
surgical they're medical they're they're
they're done by taking pills
and what this judge has done is to
suspend the approval of that pill why is
he doing it it says quote the government
did not adequately assess the drug
safety and should not have made it
accessible via Telehealth during the
pandemic obviously true and what it
means is if this stay on the drug goes
into effect the drug would no longer be
available anywhere in the U.S
there are there are going to be squish
Republicans who say oh don't do this
abortion it's not a good issue for us
it's a losing issue can't we just let's
just not talk about it please these are
the same people have been saying the
same thing for decades and decades
the only two issues on which
conservatives have won over the last 50
years
have been guns
and pro-life that's it we've lost
everything else sometimes we cut taxes a
little bit then the taxes go back up
that but we've lost on everything
why because those are the only issues
where we speak in clear moral terms
the left always speaks in clear immoral
terms
and on guns on the right to protect
yourself and on pro-life conservative
speaking clear moral terms terms and
that persuades people and that is where
we win don't go squishy now we're
talking about more than half the
abortions in the United States
are performed using drugs like this
save half those babies let's go this is
great
push forward on this it will go up to
the Supreme Court I want to hear if we
conservative in the country embracing
this endorsing this persuading their
fellow citizens that this is a good
thing this is the right thing to do
the judge has done his part let's go all
the conservative electeds all the media
heads all these people I want to hear it
there has been according to the liberal
media a muted response from Republicans
who don't want this to swing back on
them I don't want a muted response I
don't want squishies I don't want
cowards speak up for life if you're not
going to defend life you're not going to
defend anything at all
now one way that I feel very vital get
my blood pumping you know how I do it
with delicious good ranchers right now
go to goodranchors.com use promo code
nulls I love good Ranchers
it is the greatest meat ever it is so
much higher quality than other stuff you
might get similar kind of companies it
is delivered whenever you want they lock
in your price
so it inflation proves it in this crazy
economic time right now it's just
absolutely Magnificent the product is
unlike any other right now they're
giving you a free bacon for a year a 240
dollar value giveaway that's a pound and
a half of bacon in every single box it's
just amazing and then you use my promo
code nulls you get an extra twenty
dollars off your order do it subscribe
right now you can buy the meat just on
its own and it's superb meat but totally
sweet little Lisa approved but you
should subscribe because you'll save
even more money goodranchers.com use my
code Knowles for 20 bucks off your box
free bacon great meat a secure price
and a bonus 20 bucks that is promo code
Knowles goodranchors.com
goodranchers.com American Meat delivered
when was the last time you prayed
maybe a better question to ask is when
was the last time you thought about the
meaning of Prayer
many people see prayer as a way of
petitioning God for something but as
with all things concerning God there is
more to it than that
that's why Ben Shapiro describes it in
the latest episode of Exodus a marvelous
new series from Jordan Peterson
the idea of of prayer that you're
talking about is obviously a lot more
meaningful because it's really not about
changing God's mind it's about changing
who you are and thus God naturally
responds to you differently because
you're not the person that you were
before you prayed and the the verb to to
pray in Hebrew is actually in the
reflexive tense right right which is
supposed to the idea is that it's
supposed to be something that acts on
you the prayer is supposed to act on you
it's not supposed to be something where
you're attempting to pry an answer out
of God
Ben and Jordan are joined by a group of
esteemed Scholars theologians and
artists for an in-depth discussion on a
very very important book of the Bible it
is every bit as Illuminating as you
would hope new episodes are coming
online every week exclusively for daily
wire Plus members join now at
dailywire.com subscribe to watch Exodus
also this past weekend yes or no the
greatest game on the internet came back
with a new episode I sat down with my
dear friend
Brett Cooper and we bridge that
generational divide on yes or no you can
have the game yourself right now go to
dailywire.com shop we've shipped out
thousands of these it is going to sell
out again but they are shipping don't
wait dailywire.com slash shop
now speaking of things going on in
Tennessee right now you know about the
uh the riot
I'm sorry the peaceful wonderful protest
that's that's what it's it's a peaceful
wonderful protest when it's the
Democrats
uh leading people in to interrupt
legislative procedures and it's a
terrible Insurrection the worst thing
ever when conservative grannies go take
pictures in the capital rotunda that's
what happens so
now we we've we're trying to figure out
who these people are
there were three reps who pushed this
nonsense
one of whom is a Woman by the name of
Gloria Johnson Gloria Johnson is one of
the three she's the only one who managed
to survive the expulsion vote she
survived it by one vote the other two
got booted out of the state house but
she survived it by one vote because she
was slightly less egregious in her
behavior on that day so these are the
kind of people who are running the show
in New York uh Gloria Johnson
uh just recently made the claim that the
conservatives in Tennessee are trying to
bring back lynching
bring back the firing squad and the
electric chair and one of my colleagues
said I think we should bring back
hanging by a tree
um he literally suggested lynching
it's happening in Tennessee by the way I
said it was New York because of This
Woman's crazy ideas but no that that's
what a Tennessee lawmaker is saying
that's not what lynching is
lynching is
extrajudicial killing by a group of
people
lynching does not always involve hanging
lynch mobs can Lynch people all sorts of
different ways
in hanging
does not always mean lynching
in fact most of the time hanging has not
meant lynching
but most of the time hanging has just
been the punishment for a crime meted
out by the courts if a criminal is tried
and convicted
and then hanged you wouldn't call that a
lynching that is just the ordinary
administration of justice
this woman doesn't know a basic fact
about the justice system
and it makes me wonder how long
can we govern ourselves with ignorance
this pervasive
how long
can we continue this Republic of ours
when people and especially our leaders
don't know a thing about anything they
don't know I'm not saying that they have
kind of eccentric ideas or there we
would disagree on this I mean they just
don't know basic facts about anything
they don't know what a man is they don't
know what a woman is how long can we
endure
our constitution is great it's a really
nice piece of paper with really nice
fancy handwriting on it but it doesn't
mean anything if there are not people to
run the government properly
and we have such blight ignorance in
this country especially among the
leadership class I don't know how much
longer we can go on like this now the
other person who helped lead the
Tennessee riot a guy named Justin
Pearson
Justin Pearson is a preacher I guess in
addition to being a
former politician a guy who used to have
a seat in the state house but now got
booted out
here is the way that Pearson preaches
would you mind going ahead and praying
with me now mother God create a God
loving God holy God take this your
servant made from dust and connected
with the raw materials of Stardust to
speak in this moment to say something
that brings forward the word you placed
into my heart I accept my unworthiness
for such a task as bold as this and I
seek your guide as as you use me and
speak through me to the ancestor
preachers who made sermons from hymns
moans and groans and spirituals from the
bondage of slavery speak now through
this your descendant to the black women
locked out being abused tormented raped
eradicated and yet born a new and
distant future in this country into a
young colored boy named me I name you
now my great-grandmother Anna Ruth my
great-grandmother flossy my
great-grandmother everline my
great-grandmother Lavinia yeah he goes
on and on
slam poetry is the death of Art
it would seem to be the death of
religious worship
and it's now also the death of politics
he opens up he says mother God these
people who insist that we honor their
pronouns their preferred pronouns they
won't honor God's preferred pronouns
they never seem to do that why does it
matter why does it matter what this
guy's religious views are
or irreligious views I guess in this
case
because as John Adams told us the
Constitution is built for a moral and
religious people and when he's talking
about religion he's talking about
Christianity not mother God ancestor
worship or whatever this guy's talking
about but actual Christianity not the uh
what what is this place called the
Memphis Unitarian Universalist meeting
house but Christianity John Adams
spelled that out he said the the beliefs
that Anime America are Christian beliefs
the morality that animates America it's
Christian morality John Jay said this
the founding fathers said this
resoundingly
why is a politician a preacher it I'm
not on him because he's a preacher of
course government is in the religion
business
how and who and what we worship more
than anything else forms Who We Are
if we worship God we're going to have a
godlier goodlier better Society
if we worship
money we're going to have a
materialistic Society if we worship
weird sex stuff we're going to have a
lust convulsed Society
if we if we worship ourselves we're in a
very selfish Society
in that sermon he goes on he talks about
how important it is to trans everybody
they won't have to worry about folks
talking about advocating for people to
get access to health care who are
transgender children
won't have to worry about the need to
end lynching as capital punishment okay
and there it is too oh man the first
time all I caught was the the need to
trans people and by the way children he
says we listen we need to I'm praying to
the mother goddess of the spirit of my
ancestors and that is why we need to
chop off the healthy genitals of the
little children and that is why we need
to pump them full of cross-sex hormones
and sterilize the children because of my
religious views and that is why we need
to stop lynching as capital punishment
lynching cannot be capital punishment by
definition
split it capital punishment is a part of
the judicial system
if a person has a
Fair trial a real trial and is convicted
by the Civil Authority by the judicial
system and is then killed that cannot be
lynching
by definition these are the people who
are running our states
and this is going to be increasingly the
case this is a young man he's in his mid
to late 20s
this is it's not his fault that he was
poorly educated it's not his fault that
he was raised in some Bizarro
pseudo-religious upbringing
it's not
it's not his fault that this was how he
was formed
it's not his fault but it is our problem
our leaders
are just so profoundly ignorant
they have no idea
and
when all of our leaders have no idea our
country cannot fly
the Constitution was built for a moral
and religious people I'll add one little
extra to that
it was built for people who knew
the most basic facts of reality when you
want to see what's going on in reality
sometimes we engage with fiction
one great new work you got to check out
nefarious listen you know I'm a tough
critic
pretty clear when I don't like something
I don't I don't keep my views usually to
myself there's a new movie opening on
April 14th called nefarious that looks
and sounds like another completely
forgettable horror film but here's why
it's different it's not a horror film
it's a realistic psychological Thriller
that becomes a supernatural Thriller
it's about a serial killer about to be
executed who claims he's a demon the
psychiatrist is called in to see if the
man's going crazy or is faking Insanity
to get off the hook the psychiatrist is
your standard ivy league guy doesn't
believe in demons and God anything like
that but he doesn't quite realize what
he's up against
this film is surprising and thought
provoking something you definitely need
to see nefarious opens Nationwide
starting April 14th go to who is
nefarious.com buy your tickets today
that is who is
nefarious.com for tickets head on over
there right now you will enjoy it
especially this basically nothing good
coming out of Hollywood so head on over
to Whois nefarious.com
my favorite comment yesterday is from
scoot
scoot who says I can't wait for this
debate it's going to be a classic thanks
Knowles uh bad news for you scoot
sorry man I don't
I was looking forward to it too I
thought it would have been an
interesting debate but
I all I can do is accept a debate
invitation
but if
my debate opponent gets cold feet at the
very end
what can I do
debate's over before it began
I guess I won
but I still wish we could have had the
debate say la vie
say it lovey
now speaking of our rulers
2024 is around the corner
and
there's a really interesting poll that
just came out of Florida
Ronda Santos has just edged out Donald
Trump in Florida
now this might be expected because Ron
DeSantis is the governor of Florida so
he's active right now especially in that
state people are very aware of him there
okay
the reason this matters is because
Florida is the one state where you could
say that Ron DeSantis and
Donald Trump have pretty much the same
degree of name recognition
people whose nose is in politics all the
time frequently forget that a lot of
people don't pay attention to this stuff
so frequently and so Ron DeSantis
doesn't have anywhere near the name
recognition that Donald Trump has
Nationwide but in Florida they do and
head to head in Florida DeSantis at
least according to this poll from
Mason-Dixon polling is slightly edging
out Trump in
Florida great news for DeSantis
however I still think Trump has the
advantage here I still think this is
Trump's race to lose Ron DeSantis has
done a great job building up his support
among Floridians it's taken him a while
to do that and he's got really tangible
results for Florida residents to point
to is he going to be able to do that
Nationwide
it's hard to see how Trump has had such
a head start Trump is going to get so
much free publicity from the media and
the fact that the libs hate Trump more
than they hate the scientists is going
to help Trump
in the primary unless they throw this
guy in prison and prevent him from
campaigning it's hard to see
how DeSantis ultimately pulls it off but
this is good news for him this is a good
start to his campaign
it it shows that he's at least got a
shot to do it
the best argument against Trump in 2024
is that
the powers that be are just not going to
let him win again
and that's not a fair
knock on his campaign and it's not right
and it's not just but
especially if you think that there were
Shenanigans in the 2020 election
what's to say there's not going to be
Shenanigans this time how are you going
to prevent that if you think that there
are interests that can strongly
influence a campaign in an election
how's Trump going to prevent that this
time
speaking of the deep state
the FBI
cultivated sources in Catholic parishes
the FBI was spying on Catholics
simply for going to mass
as part of a counter-terrorism campaign
we know this now because of the man Jim
Jordan
who as the head of the Judiciary
Committee of the house
just wrote to the director of the FBI
Christopher Wray
and observes that based on the limited
information produced by the FBI to the
committee we now know that the FBI
relied on at least one undercover agent
to produce its analysis and that the FBI
proposed that its agents engage in
Outreach to Catholic parishes to develop
sources among the clergy and church
leadership to inform on Americans
practicing their faith so they're trying
to go
and and flip the priests on
the parishioners do you realize how
messed up this is
especially considering that Christianity
is an incarnational Faith Catholicism in
particular takes that sacramental
incarnational aspect very very seriously
Catholics engage in sacramental
confession we go into the confessional
we confess our sins to a priest we tell
the priest all the worst stuff that
we've done and we try to do it regularly
ideally once a week
and the Seal of that confessional is
inviolable
and then the FBI goes in there and tries
to get the clergy to rat on the
parishioners
can you imagine how perverse that is how
corrupt that is
Jordan goes on he says we've repeatedly
sought information from the FBI relating
to this document that came out at the
end of January entitled interest of
racially or ethnically motivated violent
extremists in radical traditionalist
Catholic ideology almost certainly
presents new mitigation opportunities a
classic gobbledygook from
from the government but it's saying that
the Catholics are radicals
especially the Conservative Catholics
the radicals and the FEDS are going to
go in and spy on them
which proves that memo that came out
that wasn't just a one-off memo oopsie
Daisy that's how the FBI tried to play
it off they said oh whoopsies that oh
that memo that doesn't meet our
standards oops don't know how that got
in there yeah okay it's gone yeah it's
gone nothing to see here
no we didn't mean that hey is that a
butterfly hey come on stop looking here
but no this was a program
this was a program carried out by the
FBI
with agents on the case
spying on Catholics
that is
scary because
it raises all sorts of questions about
how our democracy really operates it
raises all sorts of questions about the
power of the deep state
and it especially shows you just what
utter garbage it is when you hear the
libs whining and crying and clutching
their pearls over the threats so threats
to our sacred democracy posed by the
horn hat man taking a selfie in the
capital
what about the threats to our sacred
democracy from the FBI spying on
Christians going in and trying to flip
priests on their parishioners
what about that that seems like a bigger
threat to our sacred democracy than some
Midwestern grannies
having taking pictures in the capital
it's our democracy and you know do you
know that the conservatives are not even
defending our sacred democracy according
to it's according to msnbc's Nicole
Wallace
Nicole Wallace says not a single
Republican
it's doing anything to protect democracy
the Republican the corruption of the
party that you and I were a part of is
also a story that gets short drifted we
sanitize that too
it's corrupt from the top to the bottom
from east to west not one Republican
condemned the Tennessee Republican
majority for what they did not one
Republican who thought that bringing
democracy to Iraq or Afghanistan would
make our country safer which was I know
it's unpopular that was the position of
Mitch McConnell and every elected
Republican not one of them is interested
in doing a single damn thing to protect
democracy here in America here in
Tennessee not one of them
the Republicans who voted to expel
the Democrat lawmakers who led
what and and a protest that the sort of
protest that the Democrats themselves
have called an Insurrection in a coup
d'etat and these Democrat lawmakers in
Tennessee LED it
the thing the thing that the Democrats
say posed the greatest threat to
democracy and almost overthrew our whole
constitutional order
these Democrat lawmakers LED one of
those a much more serious version of
those in the Tennessee State House
and then when they were expelled
those same liberals come in and they say
this is a threat to democracy it's
always a threat
when you don't give the Liberals what
they want that's always going to be the
threat to democracy
even when it is an expression of
democracy when the Republicans in the
State House were duly elected by their
constituents
when they exercise their right to expel
members for certain extraordinary
misbehavior that the members have
engaged in
it is not the undermining of democracy
it can't be by definition that is by
definition
an expression of democracy
but what the Liberals mean by democracy
is liberalism
so if the people go in and they elect to
Trump or they elect nor Bond or they
elect a Georgia Maloney or they elect
any conservative ever that is always a
threat to democracy
according to the Liberals
because they don't like democracy they
only like liberalism now what are we
going to do about it I love that those
Republicans expelled those miscreants
what are we going to do about it
well
we've got an answer the state Freedom
caucus Network my colleague Luke rosiak
here just reported on this at Daily wire
the state Freedom caucus network is just
what it sounds like it's the freedom
caucus that you see in the House of
Representatives but at the state level
it has taken route in 11 states and
the mission of the state Freedom caucus
network is to make sure that Republicans
when they have political power use that
political power in the states
we have a lot of political power at the
state level and we don't really use it
all that well
and you see what happens when when a
republican governor and a republican
legislature
wield political power in the states
big change can happen like we've seen in
Florida under Ron DeSantis it's the
reason the Rhonda Santos is being talked
about is the number two presidential
candidate right now on the right
what about the other states states such
as Wyoming North Dakota South Dakota
Idaho Oklahoma Arkansas and Utah
they've got way more Republican control
than Florida does
ninety percent of states in Wyoming are
held by Republicans
Ohio has more Republican control than
Florida does
so why aren't they leading why are we
all looking into Florida we should be
looking to Florida on one issue and then
Wyoming one up one-ups them on another
issue and then Ohio one UPS Wyoming on
another issue
well that's what the state Freedom
caucus network is setting out to do led
by Andrew Roth who is a former executive
of the Club for Growth alongside Justin
we met probably mispronouncing that
which is the house Freedom caucus's
former executive director great news
let's do it baby this is something I've
been calling for for a very long time
wield that political power not just at
the national glitzy issues but down at
the state level too down at the local
level too
gotta wield it you got to use it or lose
it
speaking of
speaking of political power being
wielded and all these sorts of political
fights
Alvin Bragg who is the Manhattan
district attorney who is trying to
imprison Donald Trump he is now suing
Jim Jordan the head of the house
Judiciary Committee because Jim Jordan
is going to subpoena a prosecutor who
formerly worked for Bragg because Jim
Jordan thinks that the prosecution by
Bragg of Donald Trump is a violation of
our constitutional norms and something
within the purview of the house
Judiciary Committee because the house
Judiciary Committee though focused on
the federal level obviously has an
interest in what happens to presidents
and former presidents are you confused
by that yeah I'm a little bit confused
too but what it basically boils down to
is that you've got to fight between
the federal government and the and the
local government and what's weird about
this fight is that the federal
government is actually being represented
by the conservatives and the local
government in New York is being
represented by the Liberals and in this
case Jim Jordan is in the right
we're in Uncharted Territory
so you're going to hear people making
all sorts of legal arguments all of
those arguments are going to be novel
legal arguments because we've never been
in a position before we're a former
president and current leader of the
opposition is being arrested by the
ruling party
because we've degraded our country and
now we're living in something closer to
a Banana Republic
and it's going to be the Republicans on
the side of
the feds here on the side of federal
power because
the guy that they've gone after is a
former president but Jordan is right
here
this is a huge overreach by the Liberals
and by New York and I hope I I am so
glad that we've got Jim Jordan in the
fight he is the man for the hour keep it
up guys
okay the rest of the show continues now
we've got a really important video for
woke Wednesday this is the love
don't judge the latest love don't judge
video in which my producer Ben Davies
wants to see how long I cannot judge
and how long you cannot judge whatever
is in this video become a member use
code Knowles Canada wlas a checkout for
two months free on all annual plans
[Music]